in places where people are manifestly  living longer which means not that they  have better genes or the capacity of  their human machine is greater than  yours or mine uh it's just that they're  not getting the the chronic diseases  that foreshorten their lives so they're  not suffering from diabetes and heart  disease and even dementia and you look  at these cultures and you ask well you  know how are they doing it they're  moment to moment day-to-day decisions  are fractionally better than ours  because their environment is such that  they're subtly nudged into moving every  20 minutes the cheapest most accessible  and most delicious food we found  are these simple beans and Grains and  and greens and and they know how to make  them they have time honored recipes to  make them you know taste great  loneliness is nearly impossible and in  every one of these blue zones there is a  vocabulary for purpose and so they were  unconsciously making better decisions  all day long